the spider-man far from home trailer is
about to play but if you haven't seen
Avengers end game yet stop watching
because there's some serious spoilers
about to come up but if you have seen
Avengers end game enjoy the trailer
everywhere I go I see his face
listen Damus and - I don't think Tony
would have done what he did if he didn't
know that you were gonna be here after
he was gone
you gonna be in next Iron Man now well
no I don't have time I'm too busy doing
your jobs oh I'm kidding I'm kidding
look keep up the good work because I am
going on vacation
heads up Nick Fury's calling I don't
really want to talk to me resolve why
because if you don't talk to him and I
have to talk I want to talk about you
sent Nick Fury to voicemail I gotta go
you do not ghost Nick Fury that dorks
what's up we're just talking about the
trip I'm here oh I think MJ really likes
me when I first alone you're a very
difficult person to contact spider-man
this is mr. Veeck we're gonna use
someone like you on my world your world
Vick is from Earth just not house a snap
to our home in our dimension we have a
job to do you're coming with us
it's gotta be something else you can use
what about the offworld captain burns
unavailable but who's the friendly
neighborhood spider-man
[ __ ] please you've been to space what
do you want Peter I want to go back on
my trip with the girl you I really like
and tell her how I feel
MJ I am spider-man no of course not I
mean it's kind of obvious you're right
you may not be ready but this is my
responsibility
saving the world requires sacrifice
sometimes people die
it's always feel like I'm putting my
friends in danger
the world needs the next Ironman you're
going to step up or not
[Music]
get you guys outta here you're on the
jet I work with spider-man you were
through Slayer
I want what spider-man not for
spider-man
[Music]